welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar flow through
polishing and the use of multimode
ligand libraries to improve process
efficiencies it is presented by buzz la
bazoo the product support and
development manager at chromatic bio
separations my name is Judy O'Rourke and
I will be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by Pro Matic bio
separations for more information about
our sponsor
visit www.ooitech.com to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box our
speaker will respond to your questions
via email following the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and those offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming buzz la bazoo I
will now turn the presentation over to
him
for that hello everyone as said my name
is buzz logos ooh and I'm the for export
development manager a pro medic bio
separations limited I've been with the
company for the last 14 years and in
that time I've carried out downstream
processing troubleshooting and working
without products as well as our
customers alike I would just like a
short moment to mention a little bit
more about pre-medical separations who
we are and what we do for medicalized
separations limited or pbl for short is
an enabling technologies company
providing a range of products and
services to the biotech and
biopharmaceutical industries for the
last 30 years pbl supply a wide range of
via separation products both off the
shelf as well as custom through our
custom development programs we have the
capacity to produce over a thousand
leader vaction sizes and our goal with
having used in the fda mea licensed
products and processes
pvl also provides the mmm plates for
rapid greening applications as well as a
range of columns both standard and
disposable today I'd like to review the
use of multimode ligands and their
application in the flow through
polishing steps
firstly I'd like to go over the types of
purification techniques there are a
number of different methods have been
developed over the years to separate
protein mixtures and deliver a purified
protein product these methods vary
widely in their sensitivity and the
resulting purity of the target protein
differences in size can be exploited to
resolve protein mixtures
however gel filtration or size exclusion
chromatography has now been largely
superseded by membrane separation
techniques in exchange chromatography
and hydrophobic interaction
chromatography or hid for short feature
in many downstream processes and
separate proteins on the basis of
differences in net charge or polarity
these methods remain very useful
techniques in biomolecule separations
but can be limiting when the product and
the impurities have a similar charge
andr hydrophobicity more recently
ligands combining both ionic and
hydrophobic groups have been developed
the so-called
ex mode or multimode ligands which
provided an increase in selectivity and
tolerance for process of forensic sorry
to process buffer composition in
comparison to unchanged for heck alone
finally affinity chromatography remains
the most selective purification
technique and utilizes selective binding
interactions between immobilized
affinity ligands and a specific binding
site on the target protein
looking back over the last 30 years
downstream processes have changed
significantly
traditionally purification processes
consisted of a series of steps which
provided progressive increases in purity
until eventually the desired purity was
achieved however this approach involves
many unit operations which contributes
to the increased costs and time as well
as reduce yields more recently modern
downstream processes are making use of
an affinity capture step to provide a
large increase in purity at the first
step this makes the removal of residual
impurities relatively straightforward by
using one or more polishing steps where
the impurities are captured and the
product passes straight through today is
an example most monoclonal antibodies
are purified using this approach using
immobilized protein a as the affinity
capture step followed by a couple of
polishing steps multimode ligands have
grown to prominence during prominence in
recent years due to their usefulness as
general ligands for capture and
polishing applications these ligands
combine a charge group and a hydrophobic
group into one ligand structure the
example shown here is GE Healthcare's
Capital n MC ligand binding an dilution
is performed by tuning the buffer
conditions to favor protein absorption
or desorption this is achieved by the
addition or removal of salts and/or the
addition or removal of polarity reducing
agents such as alcohols or glycols
however there is currently a significant
limitation to the application of
multimode ligands in that relatively few
of these ligands are currently available
commercially as a consequence buffer and
loading conditions need to be optimized
to suit the ligands available which may
not always be compatible with the
protein in question we believe a better
approach to multimode ligand
chromatography is to produce a diverse
array of multimode ligands and select
the ligand that has the binding and
Ellucian properties compatible with the
target protein and feedstock
in view of the limitations of current
multimode ligands PDL has developed a
multimode magnetic ligand library or mmm
plate this library consists of 96
different ligands attached to a Grove
beads via a spacer arm each ligand has a
different composition of charge and
hydrophobic groups both an ion cation
groups and aliphatic and aromatic
hydrophobic groups are incorporated into
the library the plate itself consists of
a block of 96 micro columns each column
has a packed volume of 0.25 ml or 250
microliters and are arranged in a
conventional 12 by 8 array format this
enables rapid screening to identify the
ligand which is best suited for capture
or polishing of the target protein
without the need to adjust or optimize
the starting protein solution because of
this increased diversity of the
multimode mimetic higgins we believe
that their selectivity is higher than
convinced conventional mixed-mode
ligands so we see ourselves sitting
between multimode ligands and affinity
capture
the multimode pneumatic liquid libraries
are created by sequential addition of
charge and hydrophobic groups to a
triazine core structure this chemistry
is very controllable reliable and gives
rise to highly stable the finnegan's
that can be cleaned using sodium
hydroxide
a wide variety of charge groups and
hydrophobic groups are incorporated into
the multimode mimetic ligands some
examples are shown here in for instance
in the I in the ionic range sulfonates
carboxylates ventilates
amino . al-amin matino and so on and the
hydrophobic is alkylphenol and
cyclohexyl this this range provides the
broad diversity of the ligand binding
properties the multimode mimetic ligand
library or NNN plate is organized into
zones with ligands having broadly
similar properties clustered together to
simplify selection of binding an
Aleutian conditions Zone one on the Left
contains ligands with predominantly
ionic roots so binding will occur at low
ionic strength and solution at high
ionic strength zone six on the right
contains predominantly hydrophobic
ligands so binding will occur at
predominantly high ionic strength
Andalucian at low ionic strength and the
zones in the middle zones 2 3 4 5
contains mixtures of ionic and
hydrophobic groups organized into
predominantly anionic zones 2 & 4 and
predominantly cationic zones three and
five groups the aliphatic hydrophobic
groups are gathered together in zones 2
& 3 and the aromatic hydrophobic groups
are found in zones 4 & 5 to demonstrate
the diversity of the mmm plate the
chemical composition of each ligand can
be analyzed with respect to various
physical or chemical properties the
distribution of hydrophobic and
hydrophilic accessible services is shown
in the upper t plots these descriptions
are described using the Schrodinger
sweet software as expected there is
significant variation of hydrophobic and
hydrophilic regions that correlate with
licken structure likewise a similarly
broad distribution of hydrogen bond
donor and acceptor groups is displayed
as shown in the lower two plots
properties can be analyzed in the same
way such as polarity aromaticity and
flexibility as well as predicted binding
to proteins it's interesting to note
that the similar patterns are displayed
for polarity flexibility and binding to
albumin this is a consequence of the
propensity of albumin to bind to long
flexible hydrocarbon chains or fatty
acids consequently analysis of these
chemical descriptors is a useful way of
confirming library diversity
this broad ligament diversity means it's
not possible to select a multimode
adsorbent with properties directly
suited to the purification in AD
due to its ease of use the screen rule
and adsorbent selection can be performed
very simply in a couple hours without
the need for expensive and complex
automated liquid handling systems
the enemy plates are prized as mentioned
earlier of 96 discrete pack packed
cooked mini columns with top and bottom
Fritz and will freely drain under
gravity so automated that liquid
handling systems are not required but
could be used if available otherwise a
multi-channel pipette is all that is
required after equilibration the sample
solution is applied to all the columns
written and the flow through wash and
dilution fractions are collected by
drainage into deep work collection
plates collected fractions can be
analyzed using a variety of plate assays
to measure the amount of target protein
and contaminates recruit contaminants in
each fraction this allows for the rapid
identification of ligands which bind the
target but not the contaminants as
required for capture applications or
ligands which bind contaminants but not
the target has required for flow through
polishing applications
as an example of the use of mmm place
the shrimp feedstock containing a
monoclonal antibody was loaded into each
column of the library which was pre
collaborated with a phosphate buffer
matching the pH and conductivity of the
feedstock
after loading all the columns were
washed with equilibration buffer to
remove any non bound material and the
illusion was carried out with a low pH
sodium citrate buffer the conditions and
descriptions and applications are shown
here
analysis of the aleutian fractions
showed a broad spectrum of binding
ranging from zero to almost complete
binding of the loaded antibody zone two
in particular contains ligands which
demonstrated during high antibody
binding as well as ligands which
exhibited little or no antibody binding
this is highlighted in the orange box
sds-page analysis of eluted fractions
from zone 2 of the mmm plate reveals
some ligands bind significant amounts of
host cell protein and protein related
impurities in particular between ligands
c3 c4 c5 and d3 through d6 bound large
amounts of host protein but displayed
very little affinity for the whole
antibody consequently the nucleons were
interest for the development of a
flow-through polishing step for how cell
protein and product related impurity
reduction for this antibody
analysis of Aleutian fractions for HOSA
protein or HCP using time-resolved
fluorescence assay or HT RF reveals
several ligands by significant
quantities of show host proteins
particularly the ligands in rows C and D
confirming the sds-page findings
comparison of the results for the
aleutian fractions using different
detection assays reveals three ligands
exhibiting low antibody bindings but
very high binding of Xhosa protein
highlighted with the yellow boxes whilst
these ligands C 2 C 3 and C 9 bind
significant amounts of host approaching
they exhibit very little binding of
product related impurities however other
ligands such as a 11 B 11 and d9
highlighted in green demonstrated very
low binding of whole antibody medium to
high binding of host proteins and high
binding of product related impurities
consequently by screening the multimode
Matic ligand library it is possible to
identify and select multimode ligands
for the binding and removal of specific
problem impurities from the whole
antibody without the need to just apply
feedstock
sorry comparison of SDS page and hose
approaching results for this the six
selected ligands is shown here all six
ligands display variable binding of the
full chain antibody which makes these
ligands very well suited for use in flow
through polishing applications for
monitoring antes antibodies expressed in
cho cells
my
not other feedstocks this example
highlights the use of the mmm plate to
identify ligands capable for the flow
through polishing of intravenous
immunoglobulin solution or IVIG by
capturing and removing removing IgA six
ligands highlighted with orange boxes
were identified which gave more than 95%
binding of the IgA with little to no
binding of the IgG
turn now to a more complex medium human
plasma which contains many thousands of
different proteins a number of which our
interest as a therapeutic products for
use in protein replacement their
therapies the issue of protein
impurities in the context of human
plasma purification is interesting as
all the proteins are native to the human
however depending upon the application
for the purified plasma protein certain
certain protein impurities are
undesirable and need to be reduced to
very low concentrations for example
activated clotting factors are of a
concern and these the results in
thrombolytic effects if inadvertently
administered in significant
concentrations this is assuming of
course that the product is not a
clotting factor concentrated likewise
activated proteases can result in
uncontrolled bleeding episodes reducing
the concentration of undesirable plasma
proteins to acceptable levels can
present significant challenges and has
resulted in plasma product recalls in
the past consequently the mmm plates
have been used in a flow-through mode to
identify ligands capable of removing
specific problem impurities from the
product protein in this example the mmm
plate was screened for legumes which
bind Callie crime but not IgG IgG in
this case being used as the marker
protein the mmm plate was equilibrated
to the same connectivity and pH as that
of plasma and wonderlocke plasma was
loaded onto all the columns the plate
was washed to remove the nonviolent
material and a general additional
condition of a neutral buffer containing
1 molar salt and 10% hexane dial was
applied to all the columns although
several hits were observed which bound
Keller crime especially in zones 5
and that's denoted in a more red color
one ligand was identified g1 highlighted
in yellow which found 87 percent of the
Calla crime present but exhibited little
to no binding of IgG in another example
an Ann mmm plate was screened for
ligands capable of removing factor 11
from plasma the same load and condition
were used as before again several hits
were identified but three ligands
highlighted again in yellow where a
further interest which gave over 85
percent Factory 11 removal with little
to no binding of IgG as with Cal a crime
g1 was identified as a hit
you
to verify the results of the library
screens and to demonstrate the
comparability of the mmm plate columns
to more traditional columns let's open G
one was selected for a tenfold scale up
to a two and a half mil for still a
column silicate column which was loaded
with 20 mils of plasma this resulted in
a classical affinity style purification
profile with target plasma proteins
passing through the column unhindered
analysis of collective fractions
demonstrated greater than 98% of the IgG
being recovered in the flow-through
fraction the absorbance g1 bounds 94% of
the factory level present which was
subsequently recovered in the aleutian
fraction along with several other minor
proteins they and that can be seen with
the SDS page
so in conclusion we have shown that the
multimode magnetic ligand library or mmm
plate for short is a useful tool for
rapidly identifying absorbance for flow
through polishing of the target proteins
by removing specific protein impurities
this can be achieved without the
adjustment of the starting feedstock and
the diversity of the ligand library
allows for the individual ligands to
bind proteins under a wide range of
buffer conditions
once the hitch is identified pbl can
provide larger quantities of the
selected adsorbent for further
development and scale of studies or
initiate the further ligand development
program of the adsorbent
thank you for your time and attention
and I would be happy to answer any
questions you may have
Thank You buzz for that informative
presentation I would also like to thank
Pro Matic bio separations for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through April 30th
2019 as a final reminder our speaker
will follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we will see
you next time goodbye